what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time well
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us are trying to get our lunch money
right i'm here with paulina
and a very very very very special guest
mr
himself we will get to mr moist in a
second but before that do not forget
that blockfi
is the sponsor of lunch money you can go
to blockfy.com
and earn up to 8.6 percent apy in an
inspiring account
or you can sign up on the wait list for
the bitcoin rewards credit card get a
credit card get paid
in bitcoin back rather than cash back go
to block fight.com
moist what's up man and nothing much i'm
doing pretty good how about y'all
glad to be on the show this is the
closest i think i think i had to a plain
black hoodie so i
figured i'd wear it i never thought this
day would come it's been a long time
for those that do not know moist has
been commenting
aggressively very very dedicatedly
in the comments of the show for a while
so he's on
shout out to wet and soggy you are not
on the show but moist is here
no problem at one point i thought that
moist was also
wet and soggy and he was just talking to
himself
that was wild you started a revolution i
saw in the
in the comments yesterday uh people were
commenting hashtag moist gang
so you ruined the surprise polina
i know i didn't know i really thought we
talked about it
okay no we talk about it and it was
included with don't tell anyone
and then you're going to pull it
everywhere it's okay no problem okay now
people will tune in next topic
all right bitcoin and other digital
currencies
plunged on friday wiping more than 200
billion dollars of value from the entire
cryptocurrency market
because bitcoin was down how old are you
20. how many of your friends own
cryptocurrencies you think uh i can
probably count on two hands
not a lot yeah why do you think not that
many of them
uh own crypto i think it's because they
don't understand
and people who just don't want to put
their money in something they don't
understand
this is a fascinating thing because what
i think people think is that it's a
bunch of 20 year olds
and it's really not people that are like
25 to 40 years
old yesterday in our uber the uber
driver pulled up his robin hood account
at the red light and checked dogecoin
and was very knowledgeable about it and
it was just going
and all he kept saying was biden did
this
and i was like i don't think dogecoin is
reacting anything to do
with the president of the united states
but okay dude
all right next topic charles schwab is
looking
closely and cautiously at the crypto
market
said ceo walt bettinger
um he said if charles schwab the company
decides to participate in the crypto
market
we will be highly competitive we will be
disruptive
and we will be client oriented aren't
they a little late
not only are they late i don't know
anyone who says we will be highly
competitive
and we will be disruptive and then it's
actually highly competitive and
disruptive in the market
uh what do you think that most of your
friends are holding moist
in terms of financial cash cash
yeah because they think that's like the
real money
stocks no just like pure cash u.s dollar
yeah but they don't have any stocks at
all uh
they do just like some of my friends
invest but most of them aren't even
thinking about that right now and the
ones that do they invest in like
amazon just the big name companies tech
companies
and most of them are doing it like on
robinhood yeah
yeah got it where you can't take your
crypto out so what do you think about
yeah crypto iou crypto iou uh i think
that charles schwab
uh is going to get into crypto i think
that charles schwab will
actually do exactly what i think morgan
stanley did which was they started a
bitcoin fund
and morgan stanley raised like 30
million dollars for the fund it was like
nothing
um and so naturally just if people want
to be in crypto
uh they're already in crypto like they
went got a coinbase account they got a
gemini account a block by account
whatever
uh and that's what they're doing all
right are we ready for this topic
spacex crew 2 reaches orbit with elon
musk's company launching 10
astronauts in under a year so space
spacex had a launch
uh yesterday that went really well
actually
early friday was it this morning it was
this morning
um it went really well it sent a bunch
of astronauts and
there was recently a profile on this
woman named megan
hold on megan macarthur she
so she is go she is the pilot she's like
the leader of this crew
right now going to space to the iss
she's going to be there for six
months her husband sat in the same
seat the last time and he went for six
weeks i think
is that cool i think that being an
astronaut
is one of those jobs that people don't
realize how hard it is
but actually everyone just like oh
that's super cool but then like you're
like oh wait this is like actually like
the training that goes into this is
probably nearly impossible yeah they got
to go to school for forever to be able
to do that
really pretty sure because they have to
get have like astrophysics degrees and
stuff
all right okay something goes wrong
dropping big words like physics
this this you don't be smarter than us
gotta flex the vocabulary yeah
wow yeah this is really cool so spacex
developed its crew dragon spacecraft
and fine-tuned its falcon 9 rocket under
nasa's commercial crew program which
provided the company
with 3.1 billion dollars to develop the
system and
launch six operational missions i have a
complaint
i have a complaint i have a complaint
i was invited along with paulina to the
spacex launch oh yeah
by a friend some people and we didn't go
i saw their instincts because paulina
wanted to be in new york no
false fact and so some of our friends
went
the stories are pretty cool and i'm
watching the instagram stories of the
freaking rocket go up in there and i'm
so pissed
yeah could have been there they had to
wake up at like 3am would you have done
that i don't think so
yeah i don't sleep actually i sleep a
lot dad but yeah let's let's not
uh all right next all right so
nasa the perseverance mars rover
mars rover has extracted first oxygen
from mars from the martian surface isn't
that crazy
they extract it or they create it has
converted some of the
red planets thin carbon dioxide rich
atmosphere into oxygen
listen we're going to live on mars like
like humans are going to go to mars
they're going to live there i don't know
if i'm going to be alive when it happens
but they are absolutely going to have
oxygen they got or they already got
helicopters for flying helicopters on
mars anybody didn't know that go google
that
and uh i pretty much think that if we
have
oxygen i think did they find water i
don't know google you have a super
computer right here just google mars
water
i'm gonna kill you okay that was on uh
record
moisture you saw that you were my
witness if i die you know who to block
almost all
water on mars today exists as ice though
it also exists in small accounts
there's vapor in the atmosphere so mars
has water and mars has oxygen that
sounds it does not have oxygen
humans converted carbon dioxide into
oxygen sounds like mars has oxygen
and so that means that humans are going
to go to mars and we're going to have
water and oxygen and we're going to live
amazing lives
all right next time can i remind
everyone my favorite part about mars is
is that all the journalists got mad at
elon musk because he said he's gonna
create the laws on mars
and they were like you can't do that and
he didn't say it but what he should have
said was okay fine you go
then first person there gets to create
the laws
that's just the laws of space travel
everybody knows that okay i have a
quiz for you and moist what do you think
is the new world's busiest airport
you go first atlanta so
it was that was that but last year i got
surprised did you tell moist the answers
no that's surprising i know everything
all right my guess is um
singapore nope guangzhou in china where
i have been to guangzhou airport
um but how do we know the numbers are
real well so the numbers are
true because because this is of 2020
and that's when basically the whole
world shut down their airports but like
china somehow did
it this is even though that's where it
came from so
guangzhou moving on
this is this is a very voice you you're
you're a dangerous co-host
ah this is exactly what i would expect
but they happened no but they said it's
temporarily and they expect atlanta to
be back
as the no but this is what i'm saying
this is exactly what i expect
from uh somebody who is trying to
establish themselves as a
formidable competition in the united
states is when the virus is ravaging the
world
they basically go and put a bunch of
people through the airport and say oh we
have the most popular airport just to
understand why were people
traveling they might not have been it
could be fake who is verifying this
information did the tsa go
the tsa does all kinds of stuff you
can't even walk with a stick of gum
through the tsa without them finding it
they would find the right numbers here
all right so we have one
hashtag it's hashtag asklunchmoneytime
below below ask lm uh elite cleaning
tulsa asks any concerns that bitcoin has
already topped
moist what do you think nah
it's just getting started that's pretty
that's pretty deep analysis right there
i tend to
[Laughter]
in 2017 there was i think six drawbacks
between 30 and
uh between 20 and 30 percent on the way
for the asset 20xing in a year
my sense is that the current correction
in price
is a very similar situation and
therefore
i am not worried about the drawback in
fact
don't listen to what i say just look at
what i do i bought more bitcoin last
night
same wow see look moist and i are
basically friends
so what's the next question that's it
but do you have any
moist did you comment yesterday no
because i wanted it to be a surprise
man trying to stay under wraps
all right all right all right so wait
wait moist what is your favorite part of
lunch money and why did you start
watching it
i started watching because it would
literally be uploaded while i was eating
lunch
and it was short and like i didn't have
a lot of time so i was like all right
it's a 10 minute video kind of
informative
and then like there was only like the
second or third episode when i dropped
that comment
and i didn't expect a response and
somehow i think if my name wasn't moist
you probably wouldn't have
mentioned the comment they were always
very thoughtful i will say
where did the name moist come from uh
13 year old humor that's where it came
from and i had no intention of like ever
uploading on youtube so i was like it
doesn't really matter what my name is
i'll just make it moist
it has really desensitized me though to
the word moist i used to not like it now
like i kind of like it it's good it's a
net positive they probably
you probably enjoy the word now because
it reminds you of this whole experience
for those that are uh wondering that
doorbell is literally my brother
who i told don't ring the doorbell he's
bringing the freaking doorbell i told
him don't ring the doorbell
and now he's ringing the doorbell but do
you have any parting words from waste
no i want to know if moist could give
advice to the people in the comments of
youtube what would the advice be
in order to help them get uh recognized
in the comments
ah should have been should have done it
first
i'm surprised i was the first one to
start commenting like that honestly
there's there's some people who are like
religiously commenting now every day
because of what moist started i'm a
trendsetter
but they want to take my spot come here
yeah come here
this is my brother who i told not to
ring the doorbell who's ringing the
doorbell
this guy right here this one look at
that yo i really like your content
thanks that's nice this is moist what's
up
[Laughter]
there's no advertising on the show
unless you pay
what what is it read the profile.com
read the profile
up.com he wants to save that no problem
but he still rang the doorbell after i
told him not to ring the doorbell so i'm
like go give him a swirly when we get
done
that's your appearance thank you you too
yeah he he said you too voice has been
on lunch money more times than you
this was a first for joe and for moist
joe just likes you because your name
she just hit me under the table and said
knock it off that's that was
like don't don't go down i feel like
that probably happens at least once an
episode
for sure oh yeah one once
hey chill all right we gotta go to lunch
some of you are eating lunch moist is
going back to school
because if you don't go to class then
you're
a fool and you'll end up washing rocks
on the side
but you didn't do it yeah because i'm
not in second grade
moist and i think might need to remove
you as a host and have more than i host
the show from now on
oh god who would have picked the topics
though i'm so good at the time no you
can still pick the topic to send them to
us you just have no errors
you do the work and we'll take all the
credit
look moist isn't complaining voices i'm
about it yeah
see well it was a pleasure meeting you
moist i hope i see you in the comments
it's an honor to be on the show
my goal for moist is that i can get him
class credit
for uh participating in life's moments
uh none of my professors like bitcoin
though so i don't know how it's gonna
work
all right that's why they're professors
and they're not
all right all right that's it see
everybody later
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five so go check them
out there's a link in the description
that you can click on
i'm an investor a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends